Tellis Flames hockey on Sports glad to have
you with us Rick ball with Kelly Rudy in the
broadcast Booth there's weager with a shot and
that's turned away by stolar out to ma jaapani
cuts to the Middle with a shot stopped by stolar
m on the rebound out front stolar makes a save
off l i I think the referee blew the whistle cuz
he thought there was an injury cuz normally you
would not have to blow the inj or the blow the
whistle just with the skate blade coming loose
he would have been a no man's land and he had
to stay out there right and that's no reason
to blow the whistle and now he's run into by
mapani looked like he might have been shoved
into the golender stolar takes his time getting
off the ice that'll be a penalty on Andre mapani
delay call here make the pass towards cadry
cadry gets it back to the point for Anderson
but that was blocked by Reinhardt he fire a hot
pass across here's marov short handed with the
shot stopped by marst took that off the arm
marov looking for the second short hand to go
the season for the Panthers play back around
kulov pinching down the boards pu comes back
to the line stenin feeds it across there a
shot by Ean Larson off a stick high and wide
kov by the way playing in his 900th game
today here's posil the mid R posil in be
scores Martin posil makes it one nothing
Calgary watch p he takes one quick look he
sees posil all low just chips it in behind the
fence Stellar I don't think he recognize that
posil is going to put this on that he thinks
that he's going to throw back in front to Zer
and he sneaks it under the arm that's a really
good play by posil Rodriguez trying to get it
out comes right back to him just over the line
he'll skate down the wing into the Zone barov
goes for the goal it's a shot CL sh marstrom
and as Evan Rodriguez Let It Go Rodriguez with
the great shot marks him with the Fantastic
saves flam still up one- nothing first period
Gilbert's pass into the skates of cadry able one
handed into the Zone from one knee now he gets
it back with a shot turned away by stolar BR and
monu are a little bit too casual the puck Banks
it off the end boards and cadry gets a great
scoring chance now the board to a chop with a
shot and brought tripped across the gold crease
now it's a chance for hey takes a look passes
instead B back to the line of here's barov in
front T by mauck rebound they score it's Sam
reard 18th goal of the Season just as the
power play came to an end this one's all
tied up at one Matthew kachuck and watch
his great deflection in front it's going
to come to the right flank and that's bar
get it right on net kachuck with a great
redirect and now all of a sudden barston makes
a great save but he can't control the rebound
backland doesn't get to Reinhardt quick
enough and he just flicks it into the top
part pressure in the corner H slides free shot
by barov turn away marrom down and Rosa clear
talking with Eric and Ryan but watch these
key sves it's barkov just to left of marksman
the putt comes loose and barov quickly gets an
opportunity kulakov goes for the rebound attempt
play in deep weager activates cry in that tip
it to weager here's Zer missed the pun Anderson
gets it back with a shot and a good save by stard
up the Flames defenseman push it back and now how
about weager he gets it in front to Zer to Rasmus
Anderson that's his best chance weager laboring
up there HP pass back to to forsley for hanging
with a shot stopped rebound picked up by mapon
what a surprise one kept in by forsling cuts to
the high slot with a shot stopped by Mar rebound
Swept Away Coleman's on it Flames break up for
haggy right in the Main Street that's a fifth
block of the game by 10 up then the Panthers
get another opportunity forsling right in the
middle kulakov gets there first off the glass
and out tumbles right to lomber trying to get
around eimon by lomberg one shot stop rebound
scooped up off the side of the goal see how
about lomberg getting around D Simone H back to
cadri he'll feed it to the other side to Hanah
but one timer sto by solil looking for a second
stolar makes the save and covers up at the top of
the crease with a second rebound and there's
a big size of stellars he takes up a lot of
net in the corner Corner plays it back
to weager 20 seconds left in the Power
Play hubero weager One More Time Wier Love
Save Puck loose they jab away it goes wide
KNX hubero down and here's the action in front
as well Reinhardt tips it over to kach that's
intercepted and here's chance backing
short handed Michael backlin right in
scor
backl backand 2-1 calary and what looked to be
a great entrance by the Panthers it's turned
over by Reinhardt right onto the tape of hanen and
Michael backin that was a confident move it's like
he knew the entire time backin that he's going
backand sh the entire time that is a huge lift
for the Flames here early in the third period
they had nothing going on in their power play
Sher goic trying to get there mour beats him to
it Veri Bennett stopped by markr no rebound con
Chuck right there marks are able to hang on and
then could chuck and Coleman come together taking
a look and then bnet brightening the slot he gets
that one through Pass R here he is again and pass
defle back one again shorthanded trying to break
br this time M gets back that shot at the mask
of stolar is back to let it fly stolar lyol is
going to get a stick right there on the pass from
barov and now b gets this opportunity right off
the goalie's mat 20 seconds left in the Coleman
penalty shooting save by Mar as he fires out
the Trapper and hangs on gets off for a change
and EAD hoping there's traffic from weager got
the puck into the Zone off the Stick of posil
deep hubero hasle him on tour and hubo gets high
sticks that one undetected here's G to the back
hand stop by stolar and he's able to cover up
and hubor here's the entry there's the race I
just talked about winning battles brought to
stick right in the face yes indeed and then
Gilbert here's reard feeds it over for haggy
fans barov tips it across onour in deep in Fr
cut off by marer loose put cleared into the crowd
kach plays it over to Reinhardt Reinhard back to
the line of hey here's Montour marov on the half
boards with a shot tipped on goal marks him down
makes the save try to cover up still loose that
shot hit a leg comes freey can't get the shot away
close call Air onour One timer and that's loose
to the crease big save by mon got the right p
on it Puck slides back to the line broke it up
here's a chance for col for a shorty in the in
shot Al that might be an awarded well it's going
to be a penalty shot that'll be an awarded goal
as colan was slashed by vour and it's 3-1 Calgary
with a minute 33 to go that's a great call by the
officials and here's the Coleman opportunity
mour turns it over and as he comes in empty
net he trips Coleman doesn't allow the empty net
there's no question about that had monre not done
that Coleman easily would have put that in the
net so penalty shot here's Rodriguez dropped it
off with the Chuck spins gets the puck across on
the far side and there's another stop by Markman
the loose Puck chip back to the line time lining
now and the Flames about the steer Hall a 3-1
victory